If you're on hold to a company, and they're
playing music down the phone at you,
the chances are it sounds terrible, and sometimes
it just dissolves into static.
Telephone signals are not designed to carry
music, and to explain why,
we have to start way, way back
with old telephone equipment like this.
Early telephone calls were put through by
a human operator
who would be literally connecting the two
phone wires into one circuit
at a big board of switches.
Or a "switchboard".
Any sound at one end,
whether it's speech, music, whatever,
would be converted to an electrical signal,
sent down the wire,
and converted back at the other end.
You send music, you receive music --
although it'd be limited by the abilities
of the tiny microphone and speaker.
But telephone exchanges like this only work
for small numbers of connections.
Because, you know,
you can't do this for every call.
[PHONE RINGS]
Phone companies quickly realised
that they could save
on setting up thousands of wires
between exchanges miles apart
if they were able to put several conversations
down one wire at the same time.
So rather than transmit every frequency of
sound in the original signal,
they would cut off the high and low frequencies,
the ones we don't absolutely need to understand
speech,
and then they would shift each call into a
different frequency band.
At at the other end, like tuning in a radio,
they would shift each call back to the right
frequencies so you could hear it.
I mean, the quality wasn't great, but it was
good enough.
And hey, we got cheap long distance calling.
We got used to that phone-quality sound.
[EXCHANGE CLICKS]
And it became the standard.
So already [PHONE RINGS] music was going to
sound a bit dodgy,
with all the high and low
frequencies cut off.
But while we were still running
on analogue circuits
[EXCHANGE RESETS]
it wasn't going to sound like static.
That was the fault of computers.
Phone companies realised that they could send
even more calls down the same wire,
or into the same airspace on a cellular network,
if they used computers to compress the audio.
And the more they compressed it,
the more calls they could fit
at the same time,
and the cheaper it'd be for them.
These days, there is enough power
in pretty much everyone's phone
to compress 4K video in real time,
but back then, not so much.
MP3s had only just been invented,
and these do not have enough power
to compress those.
The standards for phone calls, even today,
rely on quick-and-dirty compression
built decades ago, designed to run
on very little computing power,
and optimised for speech.
That compression is great at encoding one
clear voice --
but chuck a load of complicated music at it,
with all its instruments
[COMPRESSED MUSIC]
and it's going to sound bad.
But not quite enough to break down into static.
There is one last piece of the puzzle.
Someone else cutting corners.
Because in the worst case, that hold music
isn’t just compressed
by the phone company on its way to you.
It’s already been compressed
by a completely different system
as your call bounces around a company’s
internal phone network.
An internal phone network that has
probably been built by the lowest bidder.
So the phone company takes
that already-mangled signal
and mangles it in a different way
as it travels to you.
And in a really badly designed system,
maybe there’s an entire third layer
of terrible compression
from whichever other company
runs the call centre
that you're actually talking to,
off in some other country.
[MUSIC RISES]
Speech can survive that chain
But music...
[MUSIC TURNS TO STATIC]
...music can't!
Thank you so much to all the team
at the Milton Keynes Museum
and their Connected Earth gallery,
where pretty much all this
telephone exchange equipment
is just open to play around with.
Pull down the description for more about them.
This is not a TARDIS.
This is literally just
a police telephone box.